opposition leader Robert chagani also
known as Bobby wine didn't even step out
of the plane before he was arrested by
Ugandan police they'd been waiting for
him on the tarmac he had just arrived
from Canada and South Africa where he'd
been on a political tour for his
National Unity platform
party police pushed wine into a waiting
car and escorted him home the arrest
appeared to be an attempt to stop a
plunged procession with his supporters
who wanted to welcome him home after 3
weeks of B that was not to be they drove
me to the old airport where they pulled
me out and then put me in a military car
with many soldiers and police officers
more than 15 people were parked in that
car you know it was very humiliating it
was very uncomfortable but I'm glad I
reached here Security Forces used to
disperse people who had gathered outside
Wine's
home I want to tell the world we're not
happy about how we're being treated we
slept at the airport but we kept hiding
why do the police want to terrify us why
are we being tear G Ugandan authorities
have a long history of using so-called
preventative arrest to detain opposition
leaders and Stave of demonstrations I'm
everywhere in Chains wine was a front
runner in the 2021 general election he
lost to president Yari M but claimed
that the poll was rigged he was then put
under house arrest for days during the
postelection
period his supporters say they will keep
fighting for their political rights
despite the frustrations they say they
face Katherine soy Al jaaz